pour en parler nous sommes avec thierry
amouroux porte-parole du syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
bonjour monsieur amouroux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rtl france alors
depuis hier les masques non sanitaires
peuvent être à nouveau commercialiser
dans les pharmacies françaises des
masques grand public
concrètement à quoi cela va ressembler
il faut bien comprendre que le masque
que soit obligatoire ou pas
il y est important de le porter quelles
que soient les consignes
gouvernementales il faut bien comprendre
que le le masque c'est un confinement
portatif
ça permet de vous protéger et donc
chaque fois que vous rentrez dans une
zone confinée comme un commerce ou un
hall d'immeuble
il est important d'avoir le masque sur
le visage
par contre en activités de plein air
c'est ce n'est pas nécessaire alors ces
masques seront ils tout d'abord en tissu
est ce qu'ils vont répondre à des normes
bien précises
alors les masques qui seront vendus dans
les commerces
oui répondront un certain nombre de
normes votre visuel expliquer les
différences entre les trois types de
masques faut savoir que même un masque
artisanale belle ça permet effectivement
de deux de contenir les gouttelettes et
de limiter les échanges entre personnes
donc c'est important d'en avoir
alors on sait que les pharmaciens ont
d'ores et déjà prévenu que cela va être
difficile pour tous les français de s'en
procurer ce qu'il faudra prioriser les
personnes fragiles ou celles qui
retournent au travail selon vous alors
il est indispensable que tout le monde
puisse disposer de masques effectivement
bien il y a des tutos qui sont
disponibles sur internet où chacun peut
se fabriquer un masque
avec un peu de tissu en coton et voilà à
voir
faut pas chercher la perfection et le
mieux est l'ennemi du bien donc
l'important c'est d'avoir quelque chose
qui vous couvre le visage est qu'un
maximum de gens puissent en disposer
le problème que l'on a en france et que
bon il n'y a pas assez de masse parce
que le gouvernement n'a pas
réquisitionner toutes les usines de
l'industrie textile pour nous on depuis
début mars on réclamait qu'on passe en
économie de guerre sanitaire c'est à
dire que toutes les entreprises
industrielles du textile se met à
fabriquer des masques et des sur blues
qui sont aussi un élément important de
protection pour le personnel soignant
mais il faut bien comprendre que le le
masque c'est important alors le masque
au bout de quatre heures il devient trop
humide et donc il faut en changer
par contre si vous avez qu'une quantité
limitée de deux masques et bien vous
pouvez le mettre à sécher et le
réutiliser le lendemain ou deux jours
après le temps qu'ils se soient
asséchées et que les éventuels virus
présents aient pu et puis disparaître
on parle également du prix de ces
masques on a une fourchette pour
l'instant je crois qu'il va de 2 à 6
euros est ce qu'il faudrait justement
encadrer le prix des ses masques afin
qu'ils soient abordables pour toute la
population dans la plupart des pays
européens le masque est distribué
gratuitement par les autorités
soit dans le métro soit à l'entrée des
magasins qui a quand même un vrai
problème en france
surtout qu effectivement on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya des profiteurs de guerre à
savoir que avant l'épidémie une
bourrasque une boîte de masques
chirurgicaux
c'était trois heures quatre euros 90 les
les 50 donc 10 centimes le masque
chirurgical officiel l'avoir démasqué à
5 euros de manière artisanale à une
efficacité inférieur au masque
chirurgical
ça laisse quand même rêveur
donc j'ai qu'il ment pour nous il faut
que les masques soit gratuit et si
quelqu'un doit les payer baissé à la
puissance publique de les payer n'est
pas question qu'il puisse y avoir en
plus une sélection par par l'argent avec
des personnes qui n'auraient pas les
moyens de se protéger
merci beaucoup thierry amouroux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
ce porte parole du syndicat national des
professionnels rachat